[Music]
hello it's seven o'clock this is sky
news breakfast here are our top stories
this morning vaccines for teens parents
are urged to book jabs for their
children because the education secretary
says reducing the covert isolation
period to five days would be helpful
it comes as the uk passes the grim
milestone of 150 000 deaths from covid19
two years on from its discovery in wuhan
nearly decision time for djokovic the
appeal against the cancellation of his
australian visa will go to court tonight
after his lawyers claim a positive covid
test last month met the entry criteria
but it comes as new pictures show the
world number one attending a public
event just a day after his positive pcr
test
looking for a brexit breakthrough the
foreign secretary liz truss says she's
prepared to ramp up north marlon
negotiations with brussels by triggering
article 16.
sky news speaks to the women and girls
with adhd who struggled to get diagnosed
because of a misconception about the
symptoms
and the duchess of cambridge marks her
40th birthday with the release of three
new portraits
the weather about a day for many with
more in the way of sunshine however it
will feel chilly and there will be some
blustery showers in the west
and at 42 we'll take a look at papers
with broadcaster and writer edward abu
and the entrepreneur kate harcastle
[Music]
a very good morning to you i'm jonathan
samuels parents of 12 to 15 year olds
have been urged to book kovid jabs for
their children as the government looks
at ramping up the rollout for kids who
haven't been vaccinated it all comes as
the education secretary nadim zahawi
suggests reducing the isolation period
from seven days to five days would be
helpful saying the country is moving
from pandemic to endemic well let's take
a more detailed look through some of the
latest kobe news this morning nadim
zahawi has become the first cabinet
minister to back cutting that
self-isolation period to five days in an
interview with the sunday times he says
it would be helpful
the labour party as well as scotland's
first minister nicholas sturgeon have
warned boris johnson it would be
wrong-headed to scale back free lateral
flow tests following reports in this
morning's papers they could be limited
to high risk settings
the government is ramping up the vaccine
rollout for 12 to 15 year olds opening
up more appointments for teenagers and
urging parents to get their children
vaccinated
and the uk has now officially recorded
more than 150 000 covered related deaths
since the start of the pandemic behind
each of those numbers is a victim and a
family grieving the loss of their loved
ones skies emma birchley now reports
face after face of those whose lives
have been lost to a virus that two years
ago hadn't even been given a name
now another devastating milestone has
been passed more than a hundred and
fifty thousand people have died after
testing positive for covid19
among the first was susan sullivan she
was bubbly she was positive she was
bubbly she was a
swimming olympics women champion special
olympics i mean she was just a buzzing
buzzing buzzing human being always
dancing always on the go susan had been
ill on and off for about 10 days but on
the 27th of march 2020 her stomach pains
became unbearable and in the early hours
her parents john and ida decided to call
an ambulance we had masks on and and and
and then
then we sat with her and i just rubbing
her tummy and and and she just kept
saying
i'm waiting
where are they she kept saying they're
long they're not where are they i'm
waiting
and it just went on and on and on
the emergency services were inundated it
took eight hours for an ambulance to
arrive
susan who was 56 was admitted to
hospital but the only contact permitted
was by phone and as soon as she heard my
voice she said mummy mummy i don't like
it
yeah and that was it i took the phone up
to you but she was so distraught by then
she she was just gone she couldn't speak
to us i never spoke to her no more
a decision was made to allow one of her
brothers to visit
20 minutes after he'd arrived and 26
hours after susan had been admitted she
died in his arms when they put her in
the wall we were obviously rethought
over the moon because rather than the
intensive care i said that to the doctor
and and but then when we get a medical
notes back
right yeah we read in our medical notes
intensive care
itu denied
because of down syndrome
and co
cardiac comorbidities
they don't blame the medical staff they
know the unbearable decisions they had
to make the doctors and the nurses
didn't create the bed shortages
the government did but their fury is
also focused on those who've said no to
a vaccine
and now we've got all these people
filling up itu beds filling up my tu
beds because they made the choice
not to have a vaccine they chose not to
have their vaccine our susan didn't have
that choice
the family is planning a memorial once
susan's other brother can get here from
australia
she was just lovely
she was just she was our life
yeah end of
gentleman
and i know i mean i know how these other
people feel
do you know what i mean
the thing is until and until it happens
to you you don't know
but the tragic reality is the grim tally
will keep rising yet
emma birchley sky news north london
well we can take a look at the latest
data now there were another 146 thousand
three hundred and ninety new cave
covered cases recorded in the latest
24-hour period as well as 313 new deaths
within 28 days of a positive test that
means the total number of deaths now
stands at 150 057.
22 526 further people have received
their first dose of a vaccine with 32
455 getting their second dose that means
more than 47.6 million people have now
received their second dose
207 801 new boosters or third jabs were
reported in the latest 24-hour period
more than 35.2 million people have now
had their third jab or booster
well parents are being urged to get
their children vaccinated as half a
million slots become available this
month between the 15th of december and
the 3rd of january just over half of
adults in britain said the 12 to 15 year
olds living in their household had
already been vaccinated that's up from
just 17 at the start of october and
around a quarter of people living with
an unvaccinated 12 to 15 year old said
that child was still likely to receive a
job dr nikki kanani the deputy lead for
the nhs vaccination program said there's
lots of ways for teenagers to book one
of the thousands of slots on offer
in some areas you might have vaccination
and teams going into the school or just
outside the school you know in a pop-up
in a tent or in a roving uh sort of van
um or minibus we really want to make
sure that it's as easy as possible to
get that dose and so we're trying to
make sure that we support teams to be as
creative as possible to support that
really important uptake
sky's katie barnfield is in the newsroom
for us this morning so a real push then
to get youngsters jabbed katie
there is yes i mean vaccines of course
have really been the cornerstone of the
government's approach uh to fighting
covenant and they're now really pushing
to get these younger groups vaccinated
now children are back in the classroom
mixing
after christmas so the government has
said they're going to make 500
500 000 appointments uh available this
month in january to be booked online and
they'll be available across 500 walk-in
sites and 300 vaccination centers across
england now of course uh 12 to 15 year
olds have been able to get their
vaccination in school
since september but the government
really this morning saying uh to parents
don't wait uh if you're able to get your
child vaccination quicker through
booking it online through this program
then you are waiting for them to get
vaccinated in school then do that
however we are hearing of course about
large numbers of children having to
delay their vaccine appointments because
they've now caught covered and we've
heard from one head teacher who says
that we really need to make sure that
these children are not forgotten about
i think the important thing is to make
sure
that the services are joined up so that
we um
so that those youngsters and those
families are able to get another
opportunity
as quickly as possible as soon as
possible because that will be beneficial
to them um so i think it's making sure
that we don't forget those families and
that they receive reminders of when they
become eligible to receive the
vaccination
well of course with case numbers so high
schools are one sector that really are
suffering with so many teachers uh now
having to isolate indeed the education
secretary has now become the first
cabinet minister this morning to
publicly back calls to reduce the
vaccination period at the isolation
period sorry from seven days uh to five
of course people who've caught covered
uh currently are able to leave isolation
if they have a negative lateral flow
test on day six and seven but nadim's
harley this morning is saying he's happy
to be led by the recommendation of the
uk health security agency but suggested
it would be even better if the
quarantine period
was slashed now prime minister boris
johnson has so far resisted calls to cut
the quarantine period for positive cases
despite the strain on the nhs and other
sectors like education with the
education secretary joining these calls
this morning there of course is going to
be more pressure on him now
katie thanks very much and that very
issue will be discussed throughout the
morning here on sky news because the
education secretary nadim zahawi will be
appearing on trevor phillips on sunday a
little bit later you can watch that
interview from half past eight and you
can also join in the conversation with
the hashtag philips
well world tennis number one novak
djokovic is into his fourth day in
isolation in an australian immigration
detention center today following claims
from his lawyers that he did have a
vaccine exemption to enter australia due
to a positive covert test within the
last month but
he now faces questions over images which
appear to show him at a charity event
just the day after his positive test
skies nicole johnston joins us now from
melbourne so still
lots of unanswered questions despite
those court documents being revealed
this weekend
that's right those court documents
really raised more questions than they
answered first of all
it's the issue of the infection timeline
so from those documents he received a
covered positive test on the 16th of
december but as you said we have images
of him appearing in public a couple of
days afterwards so people are asking did
novak djokovic know that he was covered
positive then had he not received the
result
a very puzzling situation there also
questions about one of the documents
the the team is saying that he received
a document from the home office clearing
him giving him a medical exemption
because he'd had a prior infection
it now appears that that was a
online
auto-generated document that hadn't come
directly from the home office which will
surely weaken his case so monday is the
big day in court his team will be
arguing that he had a medical exemption
and that there were issues of procedural
fairness
unclear yet whether we will see novak
djokovic in court he could be
cross-examined but of course that would
happen via a video link but for now he's
still stuck in the hotel behind us some
of his
serbian community supporters have been
here keeping company and protesting for
the last few days
and the political fight continues
between the victorian government the
federal government and tennis australia
tennis australia has released its own
statement saying that in its opinion it
gave players the correct information
because a leaked letter came out from
tennis australia where it appeared that
they did not so
clearly a confusing situation a lot of
blame game going on
but for the federal government they're
also getting some political mileage out
of it this is an australian election
year a federal election could happen in
the next few months and the border issue
is a big one here people like to see a
tough approach to borders and the prime
minister scott morrison knows that and
he is gaining some capital from that
very interesting and those supporters
still banging the drum uh for the star
thanks very much nicole
the foreign secretary liz truss has
written in today's sunday telegraph
about her intention to renegotiate the
northern ireland brexit agreement should
the current talks she's leading be
unsuccessful our political correspondent
rob powell has the latest
well this is the first we've heard from
the foreign secretary liz truss in
detail anyway on brexit since she was
given
the brief to carry on the negotiations
with the eu mainly over issues
surrounding
northern ireland she's written a piece
for the sunday telegraph newspaper and i
think whilst at first it sounds like
she is being quite tough you look a bit
closer and there does look like the
potential for compromise the headline
that's been picked out is over her
threat or her insistence that she would
not hesitate to use what's called
article 16 if she doesn't get
the deal and the terms that she wants
from the european union now that would
essentially mean the uk unilaterally on
its own rewriting parts of the brexit
deal it would be quite a provocative
move and it would also
potentially lead to a trade war
with the european union but i think you
read a little bit closer and actually
there are signs there
of a more moderate tone and potentially
even signs
of some sort of compromise one of the
thorniest issues in these negotiations
have been about the role of european
courts and what role the ecj the
european court of justice will play in
resolving disputes relating to northern
ireland the previous insistence from the
uk have been that the ec ecj should have
no role now in this sunday telegraph
piece
liz trust simply says that the ecj
cannot be the final arbiter of disputes
now that uh to an extent leaves the door
open for the ecj to have some sort of
role liz trust also explicitly mentions
the idea of having an independent body
to resolve disputes which i think raises
the question of whether the european
court could play a role within that
independent process to resolve disputes
so certainly feels like a degree of
pitch rolling
for a compromise eliza truss also points
to issues that she sees practical issues
with the brexit deal as it stands and
how it affects northern ireland
with regards to red tape and checks on
goods she says there shouldn't be any
checks or documentation needed on goods
if it's staying if they are staying in
northern ireland and not going on to the
republic
and the eu um i think many will point
out that many of the issues that she has
identified are in the deal that her own
government signed up to just over 12
months ago
rob pal there for us lots more happening
this morning kazakh forces appear to
have regained control of the city of
almaty following days of deadly violence
in the region there have been no recent
reports of unrest in the area which saw
dozens killed and thousands more
detained following protests triggered by
a hike in fuel prices authorities have
also arrested the country's former
intelligence chief on suspicion of
treason
at least seven people have died after a
slab of rock broke from a cliff and
toppled onto leisure boaters near a
waterfall on furnace lake in southern
brazil officials have suggested the
rockfall may have been caused by recent
heavy rain in the region three people
are thought to be missing and nine were
seriously injured
moscow has expressed disappointment at
signals sent by the u.s and eu according
to russian state media ahead of peace
talks in geneva tomorrow the russian
leadership is reportedly pessimistic
about the outcome of the talks designed
to de-escalate military tensions on the
ukrainian border
now this is a great idea arsenal will
wear all white jerseys for their fa cup
match against nottingham forest today
it's all part of the launch of a
campaign against youth violence in
london the no more red campaign will see
the arsenal side where jerseys drained
of their traditional red colours the
kits will not be commercially available
and will only be awarded to individuals
who are making a positive difference in
the community
now these are amazing pictures the gates
of hell in turkmenistan are to be
extinguished it all follows an order
from the country's president the 60
meter wide hole north of the
turkmenistan capital has been on fire
since the early 1970s after it was set
alight in an effort to burn off a pocket
of natural gas
if you're just waking up a very good
morning to you it is 7 32 we're going to
be finding out why arsenal are going to
wear an all-white kit later on today
doing that shortly but first experts in
campaign as a warning that women with
adhd are being misdiagnosed with anxiety
and depression often due to the
misconception that adhd is about being
hyperactive or disruptive lady hd can
often look very different in women but
the guidelines used for diagnosis have
traditionally focused on men as sky's
madeleine ratcliffe reports
ten-year-old rudy has adhd attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder he's
always bouncing around and full of
energy sometimes he's even hyperactive
but his 13 year old sister natasha who
also has adhd is more introverted and
has problems sleeping
she prefers to spend her time with her
snake zander and has very different
symptoms and this is the reason why a
huge number of girls with adhd
aren't getting diagnosed because
symptoms such as inattentiveness are
missed in girls or dismissed as
daydreaming the main reason to get them
diagnosed is really because at school
that means you can get some more support
and some accommodation so and it's
becoming more and more important as you
go through schooling if it's not a
lesson i'm interested in
i find myself like
almost falling asleep but not really you
really have to make a bit of a fight
basically with the schools to sort of
get them to understand that it's not
about being willful or lazy it's none of
that
it's really because it's properly
difficult boys are five times more
likely to be diagnosed with adhd than
girls even though later in life case
numbers are roughly similar for men and
women
whether that's because symptoms are
based on studies with boys or girls are
better at masking them it means huge
numbers of young women have to live with
adhd without proper support
which is why experts say it's crucial
there's more training for gps and
teachers to help them identify cases
earlier on
this is usually the experience that
women have that they become overwhelmed
they become stressed they become anxious
they become depressed
and it is incredibly important in my
view to just to try to identify these as
earlier as possible
that was the case for leanne who spent
her childhood unable to concentrate but
was only diagnosed in her mid-20s she
feels she wasted years of her life
frustrated that no one could explain why
she felt so different it felt like i was
going completely insane because i knew
that i kept like self-sabotaging my life
i knew that what i was doing was not
normal i just felt like i lost 25 years
of my life like the first 25 years from
constantly um
kind of being controlled by things that
weren't my own brains but whether that
was like looking for alcohol or um
feeling suicidal like just not being
able to actually relax and enjoy my life
at all leanne now coaches businesses to
help others recognize the symptoms as
early as possible which is a crucial
step towards better understanding this
condition about which there is still so
much we don't know
madeleine ratcliffe sky news
thousands of protesters have gathered in
a number of french cities to demonstrate
against new coronavirus rules the
restrictions would block unvaccinated
people from bars theaters and
restaurants but many are angry at the
french president who has provoked anger
by insisting he wants to make life
difficult for those who've not been
vaccinated skies europe correspondent
michelle clifford reports now from paris
for a president just months from an
election these will have been
uncomfortable scenes tear gas fired as
protesters opposing multiple government
policies clashed with police in the
french capital but streets filled with
tens of thousands of people marching
peacefully will be more worrying still
demonstrations in paris and towns and
cities across the nation to oppose new
covid restrictions emmanuel macron wants
to bar unvaccinated people from spaces
like bars and restaurants evoking fury
we are not agreeing so we are here to
say to our politics not stop sit it's
not possible anymore it's crazy because
this new lawyer
it's first separate the population
people are angry about life
because they
they feel there's something wrong with
this government
many talked of a new kind of apartheid
being proposed in france and dozens of
mps who support the new legislation have
received death threats
carol bureau bonner has had to clean off
graffiti covering the front of her
constituency office warning her to vote
against the plans she was also sent a
bullet in the post along with a letter
warning the next one would be for her
lots of emails with the title we're
going to kill you
threats of beheadings and being stabbed
they said we're bullet makers and the
next bullet that lands on you will come
from here and then i also received
threats at my home mentioning further
vandalism and then we also received a
bullet in an envelope sent to our home
the issue has divided opinion in a
nation where around 90 percent of people
are vaccinated some marching had been
jabbed but were out to demand liberty
freedom to choose and not to face what
they call discrimination if they
rejected vaccination
many on this march are absolutely
furious about president macron's
language this week when he talked about
how he wanted to make it hard for the
unvaccinated he told a french newspaper
he wanted to piss them off the evidence
suggests he has succeeded in doing
precisely that
and some in the crowd use macron's own
words to send the gesture right back to
the president if the legislation passes
it will be enforced within days and you
can bet more protests will follow
including at the ballot box come
election time michelle clifford sky news
paris
arsenal are swapping their iconic red
shirts for an all-white kit today to
raise awareness about youth violence the
no more red campaign comes after a year
which saw 30 teenagers die as a result
of london's knife crime crisis and i'm
joined now by patrick green chief
executive of ben kinsella trust one of
the charities uh supporting the
initiative this is a great idea very
good morning to you
who came up with it where did it come
from
well it came from um arsenal and adidas
um
um it's something that we're absolutely
delighted about um
ben um who the charity was set up in in
memory of um was a huge arsenal
supporter his family are huge arsenal
supporters um so we're really proud and
honored um to be one of the um charities
receiving one of the shirts um after
today's match so it yeah it's it's great
and it's a great
profiling um as well for anti-knife
crime work um as you said it's a
terrible year for london last year and
you know this is an important message to
get out about you know knife knife crime
and violence is preventable
yeah i mean it's so important isn't it
really is and and the nice thing about
this campaign it's not just today it's
not just about the kit but there's also
mentoring going on also refurbishing
safe spaces for youngsters to play
football
yeah absolutely and we all know how
important that is um giving young people
opportunity giving young people hope um
is one of the the key initiatives in
terms of tackling knife crime um so it
is fantastic to be part of this and it's
just such such a positive start to after
such a dreadful la
2021 this is such a good start of 2022.
and patrick you can't buy this kit can
you uh in the arsenal shop you've got to
earn it
you do um which is another fantastic
initiative um it yeah it is it is not
going to be commercially available um
and it's something that will be awarded
to
organizations and people who are doing
great work in this space
yeah and you talk about the great work
that's being done of course ben's family
have worked tirelessly haven't they
campaigning really hard against knife
crime um they must be very depressed at
the latest statistics
um yeah um very very depressed last year
was an incredibly difficult year for for
for us and and for the family um knowing
that so many other families were going
through what the kinsellas have gone
through and it's 13 years since ben was
murdered and it felt as if we you know
nothing had been achieved in those 13
years we were right back to square one
in fact even worse uh than the year that
bennett died so we're clinging to any
hope that we we can get a guess at the
moment um this is a is a beacon um
this uh this initiative
um and we hope that it will inspire
young people but also in inspire other
organizations to come in and support
this work and make opportunities for
young people um and really make a
difference in terms of tackling life
crime
it's very interesting isn't it that um
when you read about knife crime and you
read about violence amongst youngsters
there's a
a crucial period in the days and between
kids leaving school
and getting home there's that sort of
zone where children young people
teenagers can get into
trouble what do we do about that
well um
you're absolutely right i mean the the
key time for for admissions to hospitals
for for knife injuries is
between four and eight o'clock that's
sort of after school time
this is where we need lots of activities
for young people it's where youth work
plays such an important part
in diverting young people into positive
activities introducing them to positive
role models into and to mentors and you
know quite frankly um the youth services
have really suffered over the last
decade and in many cases they've been
decimated um we really need to
reinvigorate that sector we need to help
young people and introduce them to
really strong positive role models
because that way they will make better
choices and they will go on to achieve
their life goals and it basically is the
great counter narrative to gangs and
young people being lured into
criminality yeah of course the pandemic
hasn't helped has it it's diverted our
attention in so many ways over the last
couple of years is the government
focused enough on this
the the pandemic has what was
you know the worst possible uh great
worst possible environment for knife
crime it isolated probably our most at
risk and more vulnerable young people um
and withdrew that level of support that
is so important to them
we don't yet know the the true impact or
the lasting impact that the pandemic
would have had for young people but it's
important that
the government do try and learn quickly
and we do uh invest in our young people
and create those opportunities and try
and counter what has happened for them
uh during the pandemic
well it's a great idea a great
initiative uh thank you so much patrick
for speaking to us give our best wishes
uh to to ben's family as always um
patrick uh green there for the ben
kinsella trust thanks very much uh
welcome back time to look at sunday's
papers then i'll join by the
entrepreneur kate harcastle and the
broadcast from writer edward adu great
to see you both again uh thanks for your
time this morning um let's start with
the front of the observer shall we kate
because there is a bit of a theme i
think in the papers today and the theme
tends to be
that we've got to the stage now where we
are going to have to
learn to live
with covid and the observer is talking
about ending
mass jabs once this booster program is
over and really treating kovid like we
do the flu
that's right the mood music's changes
and there's been a shift and it's the
talk of it moving from pandemic to
endemic and we've got various reports uh
secretary of state uh talking about how
he wants to see a move from a seven-day
isolation period to a five-day isolation
period we've got another paper talking
about the fact that there may be an end
an announcement to the end of three
tests and that those would be free tests
only situated in high-risk places like
hospitals the observer here talking
about dr clive dixon's thought who was
significant in the
programme rollout last year and what
he's saying is you know we've got this
population with higher cellular immunity
we've got to move to a new normality now
we've got to learn to live with this
virus we have got to ensure that people
are stopping getting ill to a point
where the hospitalized and it a threat
to life but we have to work out how it
can be part of our everyday and whether
that's the news coming down the line
about the tablet forms that might be
there uh the ways in which we uh develop
our own uh
cellular immunity to it it's interesting
the discussion is is quite a positive
one in the fact that we know the
pandemic has affected us beyond health
economically socially etc and we've got
to start to repair the nation as we
learn to live with the illness yeah
edward we'll talk about uh djokovic in a
moment but do you share that sort of
positive vibe that um that the papers
are going with this morning
yeah we have to see um right at the end
of the tunnel regarding this because as
someone who's not just a broadcaster but
as a dj music consultant and i do
various things as well um you know as
someone who's technically um
self-employed in freelance it's not just
for me but there's a load loads of other
people out there where you know their
life depends on what happens with with
the regulation and if there is a you
know if the plan b continues for another
month or perhaps into spring which i
hope it won't it's um it's it's
catastrophic to a lot of people and i
know some people be thinking look this
is down to our you know to um it's
it's about protecting us by the end of
the day it's about the economy and it's
about us moving on so i think there has
to be
a line has to be drawn somewhere so we
can get back to some sort of normality
yeah and of course it does also
mean that we do have to stick to the
rules as much as we can which sort of
leads me on to the djokovic story page
five uh of the mail because there's this
extraordinary photograph the court
documents that were revealed this
weekend say that he had uh covid he
tested positive on the 16th of december
so therefore he has antibodies which
means that he can potentially have an
exemption and yet the day after that pcr
test uh he supposedly photographed um
with a load of youngsters no sign of a
mask no sign of self-isolating
mingling
allegedly hugging shaking hands and with
young tennis players in serbia and this
makes you think if he knew
about about the test and it's just
irresponsible i mean for most people
once you've had a positive test and you
need to isolate i think that's the case
in in most countries but i think
clearly what's
happened here and and kind of examining
the story today there is
there is this kind of element of
exemption where i am you know a sports
star and i am in a sense in invincible
and that's not the case i mean
with the with the open and with djokovic
being uh detained
i suppose it's a message which should be
clear message to people to say well look
you know kovid it doesn't matter whether
you are sports star or you uh you happen
to be affluent it can you can get to you
and you have to abide by the rules i
mean clearly if he broke the rules here
then some think he was misadvised the
misinformed by his people and that
shouldn't have happened i mean he
breached the rules if that was the case
and i mean as you pointed out there
jonathan there was no mask um there was
no social distancing and
clearly
um a spreading event
or at least spreading by not protecting
himself but protecting himself in order
yeah that court hearing uh taking place
around about 11 o'clock tonight uk time
we'll learn more then let's turn to the
telegraph uh kate what's this story
about green farm payments
the suggestion on the front cover is
actually that because we are going to
help support farmers to become
more environmentally friendly we're
going to reward them for their efforts
that somehow i think there might be a
different story that's up jonathan but
um that actually
we are going to see this rise in food
prices we know that food and fuel prices
are going to rise significantly it's
going to be a very challenging year for
us as consumers as we try and juggle all
the needs must out of our spend each
week but the price increases are due to
higher oil prices climate change when
you're farming with extreme weather it's
very difficult in terms of counter
balancing
floods and hot air the freight costs and
the bottleneck we've seen there the
labor costs increased quite rightly in
some places as we've seen bridge rises
to the right amount curve it's had an
effect consumer demand had an effect so
this kind of suggestion that green
farming is going to be the
significant reason behind our food price
increase this year i think is a little
bit unfair it's about time we as
organizations did the right thing we
have to also take into account the work
that needs to be done environmentally um
but yes certainly going to be a
challenging year for food and fuel
increase increases and the impact that
has on consumers yeah well staying with
that theme really um about us all trying
to become uh more environmentally
friendly um on in the telegraph um
edward you may have seen just a glimpse
of this story taxi drivers left fuming
over clean air zone car upgrades
yeah they're not pleased this is um a
plan to bring in kaz as it's known to
greater manchester apparel it's happened
in birmingham and bath and um taxi
drivers and business owners uh uh livid
because they said the the mayor and the
administration uh in in manchester are
not prepared to help or they're not
giving them much guidance or they don't
know where to get uh extra money in
order to help them so obviously it's
it's it's a great initiative to try and
to help the environment but to those
people who may have to upgrade their
vehicles i mean clearly especially
living
in these current times of pandemic where
they're going to get the extra funds and
it's been reported that uh andy burnham
the mayor of manchester it's not a
popular move um
made by him and not not many people are
pleased edward we're going to have to
leave it i'm so sorry it's been great
having your thoughts this morning thanks
both
[Music]